well we all know we all know with new
relationships you have to look out for
what red flags right but now experts say
you got to watch out for pink flags too
what the daily mail reports pink flags
are the earlier signs that the person
you're dating may not be right for you
okay they're like a little less than a
red flag but they're as important listen
to this
maybe they don't take pictures with you
right which thinks pink flag maybe he's
hiding you from social media
or what if you guys are watching a lot
of tv together every time you're hanging
out maybe you've run out of things to
talk about pink flag how about this one
uh you're a few months in but you
haven't met his friends or family yet is
that a pink flag i would argue that any
pink flag is like a diet red flag you
know it's like it's almost there it's
probably not good for you and it's on
its way to becoming a red flag well i
guess it would sort of depend on your
own personal criterias if i was to date
anyone
i want to watch tv and movies and eat on
the couch and hang out and i don't think
it means we have anything less to talk
about because i also like to go to
museums and go to walks and you know i
have a full life and a full character to
bring to the situation but i really like
my cozy time so don't tell me that makes
us boring because that's my happy place
i understand i like that too but but so
i'm gonna be very clear about the
differences like a red flag is you know
he's a convicted killer right red butt
a pink the pink flag like watch out a
ping flag is like oh i sneezed if you
didn't say bless you you know what i'm
saying but is that is that on its way by
the way that is weird when people ha
clap of hands who would be slightly
miffed if you sneezed and your
partner didn't say bless you
because it's just a gentle nicety it is
you know when willie and i first started
dating one time he sneezed and i was
like in the middle of cooking or
something he goes hello i sneezed and i
was like oh bless you bless you you
waved a little pink flag sorry but
towards myself i was like that's pink
flag so you need here is where i would
say if i was dating someone and they
didn't want to go to museums and take
walks and
explore and read books and like do these
other things too that is a pink flag it
is i think pink flags are things you can
adjust you can bring up talk about and
kind of fix them but red flags are like
deal-breakers i do agree with that what
if you would say like hey could we do
these other things as well
and then the red flag would be if he was
like no yeah yeah also i really do think
that in dating it's really nice for both
partners it does not have to be a gender
thing but just for both partners to come
to the table with some ideas of
something to do
that day or that weekend you know i
found this new restaurant on eater or
you know hey there's this new exhibit
that opened up i just just give me like
we should we should give ideas to each
other you know it occurs to me right now
you would be a lot of fun to date
because you're so interested in things
that you would say hey do you want not
me because i'm exhausted i'd be like no
let's stay home i have so much 90 day to
catch up on but you'd want to be like i
want to go to this new museum i want to
do this thing i think i think you'd be
really good at dating i'm a seeker yeah
i really mean that but i love a good
anyone who can't get off the treadmill
and doesn't want to sit and park it in
front of like a binge-worthy show
it's that's exhausting
the not meeting your family pink flag
i think that almost has like a ti like
how close are they with their family
have they introduced other people is
there a reason like that i think takes
layers to kind of get
into yeah and then the whole social
media thing it's like honey if you're
basing your worth on their social media
approach to you forget about it forget
about it that one is a no-go but if he's
not introducing you to his friends or
family something's going on the friends
is different than family i think yes
absolutely if they will never bring you
out
well i think the family it depends if
you're one of those people that kind of
has like
some type of emotional baggage about
introducing a partner to your family
then it becomes a heavy thing for that
person you kind of gotta figure that out
with them but if they never introduce
you to their friends that means they're
not bringing you into other areas of
their life and that to me is a pink flag
well i think it's a pink flag because
they're worried about what their friends
are going to tell you that maybe they
got other flags all around if you know
what i mean
all right well this is a really
disgusting story oh fun okay
so buckle up because
anyone who hates making your bed you're
gonna love this one oh my gosh it's my
least favorite thing to do is make the
bed well a washington post writer named
john kelly is totally with you if you're
not a tidy bed maker because he has
begrudgingly made his bed for his entire
life to make his wife happy but he
recently found out a scientific research
that says you should not make your bed
really you're not going to believe the
reason are you guys ready for this yeah
it's so weird okay
it's from london kingston's university
it shows that leaving the bed unmade and
the sheets exposed to light is your best
defense against microscopic dust mites
basically if you make the bed and it's
nice and warm and dark in there real
tight and tight
then it creates a little kingdom for
these little mites oh god it's like a
dust mite kingdom in your bed no it's
not and if you just keep it all aired
out and light and air that's the way to
eradicate that
i don't i don't i don't even want to
think about it i don't even want to
think that there's microscopic dust
mites in my bed in your bed not my bed
not my bed there's a lot of animals in
my head
and like
yeah i bet there is some crazy stuff in
my head
i mean that just makes like my inside
scope
right well here's the good news for
anyone who doesn't want to make their
bed congratulations yes
[Music]